le champ c'est ma
passion quoi c pas bien je dirais plutôt
que vous avez une voix un peu
difficile je ne peux pas associer le nom
d'un div à celui de ça ne marche pas tu
es mise à
[Musique]
pied votre voix ma présence on va tout
déchirer deour
àor vous êes nul nul je vous préviens à
partir de maintenant c'est Nag matin
midi et soir et je bloque ces paroles
moi je veux bien tout ce que vous voulez
mais c'est pas possible votre posture
vous serrez le popo et maintenant vous
laissez sortir
[Musique]
l'air on a la compte 3 semaines il faut
tout savoir sur le bout des doigts ce
soir je suis bleu vers les coups de
minuit je pas te blesser alors je dis
que tu es min mimi mini ah il comme ça
au France et on est morte si on se
qualifie ce soir c'est dire to pour le
Championnat du Monde la me
[Musique]
du vous comptez qu même pas
[Applaudissements]
gag pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas vous détendre
you